hey guys quick video on how to get the
secret raid shader in destiny the taken
king there's a shader that's hidden to
you until you get a piece of raid armor
once you get that and you go to the
kiosks you're going to notice that in
the raid section there's a new shader
called bone marrow the bone marrow
shader requires you to have the helm the
chest the gloves and the boots in the
normal raid to get it once you've
acquired all for armor pieces either on
one character or through your alts
either take all four pieces for that
single class or from the multiple other
classes you have and combine them onto
one character does it matter if they
match as long as you have all four
pieces the helm the gloves the chest and
the boots once you've acquired them all
head back to the kiosk and acquire your
new secret raid shader bone marrow here
you can see the shader on bodybugg 88
one of my raid members it looks very
similar to the weapons that you will get
in the Kings fall it's kind of got that
white and maroonish red color tint to it
so tell me if you like the bone marrow
shader if you think you're going to try
to get it has Oryx crude you like you
screwed me by not giving you the helm
and leave those thoughts in the comments
below stay tuned to gamespot com for
more destiny coverage
you